how can we quickly find the square of
any three digit number
let's see
209 squared let us take the first digit
from the left and group the remaining
digits
so we'll have 2 and 0 9 now we'll make
three parts below on the left side we'll
write 2 squared
in the middle we will write 2 multiplied
by these two digits therefore it will be
2 multiplied by 2 multiplied by 0 9
on the right side we will write the last
digit number that is 0 9 squared
2 squared is 4 the product of this will
be 36 and 9 squared is 81 but you need
to remember that when we are squaring a
three digit number then in the middle as
well as the right there will only be two
digits so if you want to find 425
squared then the calculation will be
like this
by solving it further we will get this
answer
now using this trick can you tell us the
value of 305 squared in the comment
section
if you liked the video then hit the like
button and do subscribe to our youtube
channel